International Women's Day the day that
men with girlfriends wake up see the
words International Women's Day trending
on Facebook and suddenly wonder do
I have to do something right now it took
place on Tuesday and around the world
countries celebrated with varying
degrees of success for instance in
Russia where it's observed as a public
holiday Vladimir Putin went on TV with a
message for women the regulation dear
women I wholeheartedly congratulate you
on International Women's Day still
spirit you have time for everything
manage a great load of issues and stay
gentle bright and charming first of all
it's a little strange to hear a warm
message from a man who looks like he's
perpetually crushing a baby bird in his
fist and second if he's trying to be
progressive he's failing here because
managing a great load of issues while
staying gentle and charming is exactly
the double standard that women are
constantly try to overcome oh yes women
it is great to see you're so confident
capable and career-focused and sometimes
you're not even a shrill about it
it's very nice meanwhile we were in
Turkey president reject her one use his
Women's Day speech to make a point you
might not expect bin Ameche I know there
will be some who will be annoyed but for
me a woman is above all a mother but I
would in my opinion the greatest wrong
that you can do to a woman is to
restrict her to live a life where she is
the victim of her economic independence
ok ok ok first a woman is above all a
mother is not even appropriate to say on
Mother's Day
and also economic independence is far
from the greatest wrong you can do to a
woman there is a list that runs from
genital mutilation through Nancy Meyers
movies that you need to get through
first as for China a shopping mall their
offer discounts in honor of Women's Day
but only to good-looking women after
their facial appearances were scored by
a face scanner and I'll say this it's
not often you hear a news story that
appears to have taken place
simultaneously in the distant future and
the distant past but but it is amazing
that somewhere in China a t.j.maxx
manager will have uttered the phrase
sorry the robot doesn't want to you
those capri pants are full price and at
this point you will be glad to know that
here in the US women marked their own
day for instance Fox News's Greta Van
Susteren delivered a commentary in honor
of the event and let me just tell you in
advance if you think you know where this
is going you are wrong the Taliban won't
let women listen to music go to school
or leave the house without being covered
head to toe in a burqa women around the
world living under Sharia law and who
are the unthinkable simply for being
women which brings me to this on this
International Women's Day Eve it'd be a
good time for us women to recognize that
American men
let's give American men a shout out yes
Greta Van Susteren marked international
women's day with a shout out to American
men for being better than the Taliban I
didn't even know I didn't even know this
was possible but but I'm pretty sure she
just leaned out and and she wasn't even
done things aren't perfect for instance
we still don't have equal pay for equal
work but American men are by far very by
far the best man on the planet and we
American women we may not say it but we
know that an American men deserve to
hear that from us you know there may be
no more fitting tribute to the state of
women internationally than someone
giving men credit for doing basically
nothing